[Musique]
bonjour il ya quelques années à la suite
d'un problème d'inscription m'avait
demandé de faire un cours d'économie de
30 heures à quatre étudiants
pour vous donner une petite idée du
court ça ressemblait à ça alors
évidemment je sais ce que vous pensez
c'est quelque chose de basique c'est
élémentaire c'est facile c'est la
macroéconomie standard de deux premières
années et pour mes étudiants ont fait ça
n'était pas si facile que ça et pour les
aider pour en échasses plus conviviales
comme ils étaient 4 j'aurais demandé de
s'approcher et grâce à cette proximité
spatiale leur faible nombre pour la
première fois j'étais en mesure
d'évaluer leur compréhension en temps
réel hélas ce que j'ai vu c'est que en
fait il comprenait pas grand chose à ce
que j'expliquais comprenait beaucoup
moins bien et beaucoup moins vite que ce
que je pensais jusqu alors j'étais
victime sans le savoir d'un biais
cognitifs identifiés par les
psychologues qui correspond à ce qu'on
appelle la malédiction de la
connaissance
alors de quoi s'agit-il c'est cette
tendance de celui qui explique ce que je
suis en train de faire leur a prêté à
ses interlocuteurs sans s'en rendre
compte des connaissances préalables
qu'ils n'ont pas encore mais qui
évidemment leur serviraient pour
comprendre cette tendance provient tout
simplement du fait qu'on a du mal à
imaginer une fois qu'on sait ce que
c'est de ne pas savoir
on est en quelque sorte maudit par son
savoir alors je vais faire une petite
expérience qui va vous permettre de
comprendre un petit peu mieux senonches
pas là votre objectif ici c'est de
reconnaître la musique que je vais
tapoter de près donc je l'essayé 1
certains d'entre vous ont reconnu très
peu mais ce que je sais c'est que moi au
moment où j'ai étape haute et j'ai eu de
cette musique en tête et ce qui m'a
donné l'impression subjective que cette
musique était beaucoup plus facilement
reconnaissable qu'elles ne l'étaient
vraiment pour casser le suspense en tout
cas pour ceux qui n'avaient pas
découvert voilà de quoi il s'agissait
[Musique]
maintenant je vais vous demander
je vais tapoter à nouveau mais je vais
vous demander de ne pas penser à allons
enfants de la patrie donc essayé ne
pensez pas allons enfants de la patrie
évidemment vous vous n'y arrivais plus
vous avez déjà la musique en tête
en fait vous venez d'être victime de la
malédiction de la connaissance
si vous deviez à votre tour expliquer
quelque chose expliquait le chemin une
autre personne
vous risqueriez à votre tour d'être
victime de cette même malédiction par
exemple si vous demandez à quelqu'un
là-bas de la régie comment à partir
d'ici on peut rejoindre le parking
souterrain alors voilà ce qu'elle risque
de vous expliquer j'ai accéléré sur la
fin
vous allez sortir de l'auditorium
vous voyez vous suivez vous descendez
désespérée dans les tâches tourner à
droite assurent même près de toi on va
dire c'est qu'ils sont de rigueur
la tension était encore vive
tu crois bien développé là vous verrez
vos démarches vous portez vous êtes vous
parking du personnel ça c'est ce que
vous allez entendre mais regardez ça
c'est ce qu'elle va voir est ce qu'elle
va visualiser au moment où elle va vous
donner ses explications
vous allez sentir de l'auditorium oui le
tapis rouge
vous suivez vous descendez les escaliers
dans les tâches vous tournez à droite
sur vous même faites demi tour
vous reprenez les autres escaliers qui
descendent encore d'un étage une fois
que vous avez descendus ce deuxième
escalier vous tournez à droite encore
sur vous même et vous allez en direction
des distributeurs de boissons la vuvu
déporté sur la gauche vous continuez
vous remontez un pouvoir en béton est au
bout de ce couloir vous verrez un
panneau bleu réservée au personnel
là vous verrez une volée de marches
passé de bord personnel voilà vous
comprenez ce qui se passe au moment où
elle vous explique
elle ne peut pas ne pas visualiser le
chemin c'est ce qui lui permet
d'expliquer et c'est ce qui lui donne
aussi l'impression d'être plus clair
qu'elle ne l'est
vraiment pour ceux qui écoutent les
choses pour la première fois alors
évidemment au quotidien on arrive à
communiquer on arrive à se mettre à la
place de notre interlocuteur mais est ce
que montrent les études c'est que en
fait c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
faire qu'on ne croit habituellement
et la malédiction des connaissances
porte aussi sur des connaissances
purement factuel il ya quelques temps où
quelques années en fait j'avais posé la
question suivante à une centaine
d'étudiants de première année
alors c'est pas si beaucoup d'entre vous
connaissent la réponse mais la réponse
en fait cette question c'était martine
aubry qui est actuel maire de lille et
40% environ des étudiants étaient en
mesure de donner cette réponse
évidemment aujourd'hui étant donné
l'état du parti socialiste si je devais
poser à nouveau la question
j'aurai un taux de réponse beaucoup plus
faible en tout cas dans un deuxième
temps j'ai posé cette question qui était
quel est le pourcentage d'étudiants de
première année qui connaissent la bonne
réponse alors ceux qui ne savais pas
pour qui la réponse la question
paraissait difficile 20 us ont eu
tendance à penser que cette réponse
était aussi difficile pour les autres et
ils ont estimé en moyenne que 34 % des
étudiants seraient capables de donner la
bonne réponse vous voyez c'est pas très
loin de du vrai pourcentage maintenant
ceux qui connaissaient ceux pour qui il
était évident que martine aubry était le
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
ont eu tendance à penser que évidemment
tout le monde connaissait la réponse est
cette fois-ci l'été vous prédisez que
65% des gens seraient capables de
prédire cette réponse la malédiction des
connaissances peut prendre des formes
parfois très subtil regardez
l'expérience de suivante
imaginez quelqu'un on va l'appeler
christine c qui est dans cette pièce est
qui
fini de lire un livre et qui choisit de
le ranger ici dans la boîte bleue
christine sait s'en va entre une
personne et cette personne à l'insu
christine choisi de déplacer les boîtes
quand tu regardes et christine revient
et la question qui était posée aux
participants de cette expérience était
la suivante où christine va-t-elle
regarder en premier je vous laisse
quelques instants de réflexion faite si
vous réfléchissez à la question vous
allez à voir venir avec des réponses qui
sont plausibles
la première c'est que christine va
regarder en fait dans la boîte bleue si
elle a gardé la mémoire de la boîte dans
laquelle elle a déposé libre elle va
d'abord se diriger vers la boîte bleue
est effectivement 71 % des participants
donné cette réponse
maintenant peut-être que certains
d'entre vous se sont dit peut-être après
tout que christine n'a pas gardé la
mémoire de la couleur de la boîte 1 à
garder en mémoire que son emplacement et
pour cette raison elle se dirigera
peut-être plutôt vers celle ci dans
l'expérience originale 23 % des gens
donner cette réponse dans un second
scénario
les participants étaient invités
cette fois ci à répondre à la même
question mais pas retiennent un scénario
tout petit peu différent donc le début
elle-même christine dépose son livre
dans la boîte bleue puis s'en va entre
quelqu'un qui à l'insu christine cette
fois ci à garder ce qui va faire choisi
de déplacer le livre dans la boîte rouge
puis déplace à nouveau les boîtes même
question christine revient ou va-t-elle
regarder en premier
alors il est évident que christine ne
sait pas que le livre a été déplacé dans
la boîte rouge et donc si vous devez
répondre à cette question vous ne
devriez pas tenir compte du de cette
information
en pratique ce qu'on montre les
chercheurs c'est que
un certain nombre de participants ont
beaucoup de mal à ne pas utiliser cette
information privilégiée
rappelez-vous ça c'était les
pourcentages qu'on avait obtenu dans le
premier scénario
dans ce second scénario désormais plus
l'individu pense qu'il est possible et
même probable que christine regarde
d'abord dans la boîte rouge
alors vous comprenez le phénomène de la
malédiction des connaissances est un
phénomène insidieux dont on a du mal à
se débarrasser
ici je voudrais juste avec vous proposer
quelques quelques leçons que j'ai tiré
mon expérience de professeur d'économie
depuis une vingtaine d'années tous les
jours soumis à cette malédiction de la
connaissance
petit conseil que vous pourrez vous même
utiliser chaque fois vous aurez à
transmettre vos connaissances que ce
soit donc formateur manager ou tout
simplement parents d'élèves
le premier conseil est un petit peu
évident mais à mais vaut le coup d'être
rappelé le premier conseil s'est
improvisé pas préparé si vous ne
préparez pas en fait vous préparez vous
allez voir que la plupart du temps vous
ne maîtrisez pas bien ce que vous
pensiez maîtrisé et si vous ne préparez
pas ça va ça n'est pas compliqué ou ne
serait tout simplement pas bon mais ce
que montre la malédiction de la
connaissance et que non seulement vous
ne serez pas bon mais en plus vous n'en
serait pas conscient qui est sans doute
pire
deuxièmement vous laissez pas bluffé par
les acquiescement les hochements de tête
ou les sourire approbateur et j'en ai vu
quelques uns ici depuis tout à l'heure
j'ai un collègue qui récemment a dû
faire un cours sur deux jours un cours
intensif
il avait en face de lui deux étudiants
qui étaient particulièrement attentifs
particulièrement intéressés et qui
continuellement leur lancée par des
hochements de tête par des sourires ce
qui lui mettait la pression
en fait il essayait de compliquer un
petit peu son cours il se demander mais
qui sont ces étudiants qui semble tout
comprendre pour qui tout semble
très évident et le lendemain avant de
commencer son nouveau court quand même
essayer d'aller les voir et là en fait
il a découvert que les deux étudiants en
question étaient chinois ne parlait pas
français
et en fait n'avait absolument rien
compris à ce qu'il avait expliqué la
veille
d'accord simplement on ne pouvait pas
s'empêcher de hocher la tête et de
d'acquiescer à chaque fois que le
professeur les regarder la troisième
leçon que je tire de mon expérience
c'est quand tu es possible préférez la
version courte
or quand vous êtes lancés dans vos
explications vous êtes un petit peu
grisés par vos explications mais le
problème c'est que la plupart du temps
vos interlocuteurs ne le sont pas et la
plupart du temps ils ont une capacité
d'attention qui est beaucoup plus
réduite que celle que vous leur prêtez
et c'est d'ailleurs le conseil que je
vais m'appliquer immédiatement vous
remerciant pour votre attention
[Applaudissements]